So I'm embarrassed that I have a career,
I talk about things like trust and
cooperation and there should be no
demand for my work,
but the fact of the matter is,
is there is demand for my work,
which means that there's an opportunity,
it means that trust and cooperation are
not yet standard in our organizations
and yet they should be.
And we know that which is why we're
looking for ways to bring those things
to our organizations.
So I thought I would do something a
little different today.
You know,
when you're speaking to tens of
thousands of people and you have the
opportunity to share a message,
of course,
most rational people would say,
let's go with something I've talked
about lots of times and I'm really good
at,
but I'm not normal.
So I'm going to do something completely
new and I hope this works out.
Um,
there are two things that I think the
great leaders need to have empathy and
perspective.
And I think these things are very often
forgotten.
Leaders are so often and so concerned
about their status of their position in
and organization.
They actually forget their real job and
the real job of a leader is not about
being in charge.
It's about taking care of those in our
charge and I don't think people realize
this and I don't think people train for
this when we're junior.
Our only responsibility is to be good at
our jobs.
That's all we really have to do and some
people actually go get advanced
educations on so that they can be really
good at their jobs.
Accountants or whatever.
Right,
and you show up and you work hard and
the company will give us tons and tons
of training,
how to do our jobs.
They'll show us how to use the software.
They'll send us away for a few days to
get trained in whatever it is that we're
doing for the company and then they
expect us to go be good at our jobs and
that's what we do.
We worked very hard and if you're good
at your job,
they'll promote you and at some point
you'll get promoted to a position where
we are now responsible for the people
who do the job we used to do,
but nobody shows us how to do that and
that's why we get managers and not
leaders because the reason that our
managers are micromanaging us is because
they actually do know how to.
They do do the job better than us.
That's what got them promoted.
Really what we have to do is go through
a transition.
Some people make it quickly,
some people make it slowly and
unfortunately some people will never
make that transition at all,
which is we have to go this through.
This transition of being responsible for
the job and then turning into somebody
who's now responsible for the people who
responsible for the job.
And as I said before,
one of the great things that is lacking
in most of our companies is that they
are not teaching us how to lead.
And leadership is a skill like any other
is a practice double learnable skill,
and it is something that you work on it.
It's like a muscle.
If you practice it all the days,
you will get good at it and you will
become a strong leader.
If you stop practicing,
you will become a weak leader like
parenting.
Everyone has the capacity to be a
parent,
doesn't even.
Everybody wants to be a parent and
doesn't mean everybody shouldn't be a
apparent leadership is the same.
We all have the capacity to be a leader.
Doesn't mean everybody should be a
leader and it doesn't mean everybody
wants to be a leader.
And the reason is because it comes at
great personal sacrifice.
Remember,
you're not in charge,
you're responsible for those in your
charge.
That means things like when everything
goes right,
you have to give away all the credit and
when everything goes wrong,
you have to take all the responsibility.
That sucks,
right?
It's things like staying late to show
somebody what to do.
It's things like when something does
actually break,
when something goes wrong,
instead of yelling and screaming and
taking over,
you say try again.
When the overwhelming pressures are not
on them,
the overwhelming pressures are on us.
At the end of the day,
great leaders are not responsible for
the job.
They're responsible for the people who
are responsible for the job.
They're not even responsible for the
results.
I love talking to ceos and say,
what's your priority?
And they put their hands on.
Their hips will proudly say,
my priority is my customer.
I'm like really?
Even talked to a customer in 15 years.
There's no CEO on the planet responsible
for the customer.
They're just not the responsible for the
people who are responsible for the
customer.
I'll tell you a true story.
A few months ago I stayed at the four
seasons in Las Vegas.
It is a wonderful hotel and the reason
it's a wonderful hotel is not because of
the fancy beds.
Any hotel can go and buy a fancy bed.
The reason it's a wonderful hotel is
because of the people who work there.
If you walk past somebody at the four
seasons and this and they say hello to
you,
you get the feeling that they actually
wanted to say hello to you.
It's not that somebody told them that
you have to say a load of all the
customers,
say hello to all the guests.
Right.
You actually feel that they care now in
their lobby,
they have a coffee stand and I want.
One afternoon I went to buy a cup of
coffee and there was a Barista by the
name of Noah who was serving me.
Noah was fantastic.
He was friendly and fun,
and he was engaging with me and I had so
much fun buying a cup of coffee.
I actually think I gave 100 percent tip,
right?
He was wonderful.
So as is my nature,
I asked Noah,
do you like your job?
And without skipping a beat,
Noah says,
I love my job,
and so I followed up.
I said,
what is it that the four seasons is
doing that would make you say to me,
I love my job and without skipping a
beat,
Noah said throughout the day,
managers will walk past me and asked me
how I'm doing,
if there's anything that I need to do my
job better.
He said,
not just my manager,
any manager,
and then he said something magical.
He says,
I also work at Caesar's Palace and
Caesar's at Caesar's palace.
The managers are trying to make sure
we're doing everything right.
They catch us when we do things wrong.
He says,
when I go to work there,
I like to keep my head under the radar
and just get through the day so I can
get my paycheck.
He says,
here at the four seasons,
I feel I can be myself.
Same person,
entirely different experience from the,
from the customer who will engage with
Noah,
so we in leadership are always
criticizing.
The people were always saying,
we've got to get the right people on the
bus.
I've got a film.
Ironic my team.
I've got to get the right people,
but the reality is it's not the people.
It's the leadership.
If we create the right environment,
we will get people like Noah at the four
seasons.
If we create the wrong environment,
we will get people like Noah at Caesar's
palace.
It's not the people,
and yet we're so quick to hire and fire.
You can't hire and fire your children if
your kids are struggling.
We don't say,
you got to see at school,
you're up for adoption,
so why is it that when somebody has
performance problems at work,
why is it that our instinct is to say,
you're out.
We do not practice empathy.
What does empathy look like?
Here's the lack of empathy.
This is normal in our business world.
You walk into someone's office,
someone walks into our office and says,
your numbers have been down for the
third quarter in a row.
You have to pick up your numbers.
Otherwise,
I can't guarantee what the future will
look like.
How inspired you think that person is to
come to work the next day?
Here's what empathy looks like.
You walk into someone's office,
someone walks into your office and says,
your numbers of down for the third
quarter in a row.
Are you okay?
I'm worried about you.
What's going on?
We all have performance issues.
Maybe someone's kid is sick.
Maybe they having problems in their
marriage.
Maybe one of their parents is dying.
We don't know what's going on in their
lives,
and of course it will affect performance
at work.
Empathy is being concerned about the
human being,
not just their output.
We have for some reason our work world
has changed over the past 20 and 30
years.
We are suffering the side effects of
business theories left over from the
eighties and nineties and they are bad
for people and they are bad for
business.
Let me give you an example.
The concept of shareholder supremacy was
a theory proposed in the late 19
seventies.
It was popularized in the eighties and
nineties.
It is now standard form today.
You talked to any public company and you
ask them their priority and they say
maximize shareholder value.
Really,
that's like a coach prioritizing the
needs of the fans over the needs of the
players.
How are you going to build a winning
team with that model,
but that's normal today.
We don't even perceive it as broken or
damaged or wrong or outdated.
Remember the eighties and nineties were
boom years with relative peace and a
kinder,
gentler cold war.
Nobody was practicing,
hiding under their desks in school
anymore.
We are no longer in those times.
These are no longer boom years.
These are no longer peaceful times and
those models cannot work today.
Here's another one.
Mass layoffs.
Using someone's livelihood to balance
the books,
right?
It's so normal in America today that we
don't even understand how broken and how
damaging it is,
not only to human beings but to
business.
You know,
companies talking about how they want to
build trust and cooperation and then
they announced a round of layoffs.
Do you know the quickest way to destroy
trust and destroy cooperation and a
business literally in one day lay people
off and everyone gets scared,
right?
Can you imagine sending someone home to
say,
honey,
I can no longer provide for our family
because the company missed its arbitrary
projections this year
and forget about the people who lost
their job.
Think about the people who kept their
jobs because every single decision a
company makes as a piece of
communication and the company,
the company has just communicated to
everybody else.
This is not a meritocracy.
We don't care how hard you work or how
long you've worked here.
If we miss our numbers and you happen to
fall on the wrong side of the
spreadsheet,
I'm sorry,
we cannot guarantee employment.
In other words,
we come to work everyday afraid and
we're asking our youngest generation to
work in environments where.
How would any of us ever stand up and
admit I made a mistake?
We're cousins being told,
you have to be vulnerable.
Leaders are vulnerable.
What does that even mean?
It doesn't mean you walk around crying.
I'm vulnerable,
right?
Know what vulnerability means is you
create an environment in which someone
feels safe enough to raise their hand
and said,
I don't know what I'm doing.
You've given me a job and I haven't been
trained to do it.
I need help.
I made a mistake.
I screwed something up.
I'm scared.
I'm worried.
All of these things,
no one would ever admit inside a company
because it puts a target on your head in
case there is another round,
and so we keep it to ourselves and how
can a company ever do well if nobody's
ever willing to admit they made a
mistake that's scared or they don't know
what they're doing,
and so we've literally created cultures
in which every single day everybody
comes to work in light,
high lies highs and fakes,
and we're asking our youngest generation
to work and succeed and find themselves
and build their confidence and overcome
their addiction to technology and build
strong relationships at work.
We're asking them to do this and these
environments we've created.
We keep saying to them,
you're the future leaders.
We're the leaders.
Now
we're in control.
What are we doing?
This is what empathy means.
It means if there's an entire generation
struggling,
maybe it's not them.
It's like,
you know,
the only thing that,
the common factor in all my failed
relationships me,
same thing,
oh,
we just can't get the right performance
out of our people.
Maybe it's you're right.
It's not a generation.
It's not them.
They're not difficult or hard to
understand.
They're human beings like the rest of us
trying to find their way,
trying to work in a place where they
feel that someone cares about them as a
human being.
By the way,
that's what we all want.
In other words,
it's not even generational.
It's all of us.
This is the practice of empathy that
have wished,
struggling to communicate to someone if
it's struggling to help someone be at
their natural best.
I'm tired of people saying to me,
how do I get the best out of my people?
Really,
that's what you want.
They're like a towel.
Just ring them.
How can I get the most out of them?
No.
How do I help my people be at their
natural best,
right?
We're not asking these questions.
We are not practicing empathy.
We have to start by practicing empathy
and relate to what they may be going
through and it will profoundly change
the decisions we make.
It will profoundly change the way we see
the world.
Someone's driving to work.
You're driving to work and someone wants
to cut into your lane.
What do you do?
You pull your car up with you.
Let them in.
Most of us pull our cars up and go like
this.
You wait your turn.
Now let's practice empathy.
I don't know.
Maybe they've been out of work for six
months.
Maybe they had trouble getting the kids
out to school this morning and now
they're running late for a really
important interview and they just have
to get to this interview and they're
going to cut into our lane or maybe
they're just a bastard.
I don't know,
but
that's the point we don't know.
We don't know,
and the practice of empathy will say,
I'll let them in and I'll arrive to work
one car length lead,
right?
We don't always have to be,
right.
We don't always have to be in charge.
We don't have to be the one who
succeeds.
It's not about winning or losing,
and that's where I go to the second
point after empathy comes perspective
where it's not about winning or losing
in Game Theory,
there are two kinds of games.
There are finite games and there are
infinite games and this is how you're
going to change your perspective,
right?
A finite game is defined as known
players,
fixed rules and an agreed upon objective
baseball.
For example,
we know the rules,
we all agreed to the rules and whoever
has more runs at the end of nine innings
is the winner and the game is over.
No one ever says,
if we can just play two more innings,
I know we can come back.
Doesn't work that way.
The game is over,
right?
That's a finite game.
Then you have an infinite game.
Infinite Games are defined as known and
unknown players.
The rules are changeable and the
objective is to keep the game in play,
to perpetuate the game.
When you pit a finite player versus a
finite player,
the system is stable.
Baseball is stable,
right?
When you put an infinite,
an infinite player versus an infinite
player,
the system is also stable like the cold
war for example,
because there cannot be a winner and a
loser.
There are no winners and losers in an
infinite game,
right?
It doesn't exist and because there are
no winners or losers,
what ends up happening in the infinite
contest,
his players drop out when they run out
of the will or the resources to play,
but there's no winners or losers.
Problems arise when you pit a finite
player versus an infinite player because
in a finite player is playing to win and
an infinite player is playing to keep
the game going,
right?
This is what happened to us in Vietnam.
We were playing to win and the
Vietnamese were fighting for their
lives.
We were the ones who got stuck in
quagmire.
This was the Soviet Union and
Afghanistan.
They were trying to beat the Mujahideen
and the majority and would fight for as
long as is necessary.
Quagmire.
Now,
let's look at business.
The game of business has preexisted or
has existed long before every single
company that exists on this planet
today,
and it will outlast every single company
that he lives that exists on this planet
today.
There's no winning the game of business,
and the reason is is because we haven't
agreed to the rules.
I get such a kick out of this.
You realize how many companies actually
don't know the game they're in,
right?
Listen to the language of the companies
use.
We're trying to beat our competition.
We're trying to be number one.
Did you know that we were ranked number
one?
Look at the listing based on what
criteria,
revenues,
profits,
marketshare square footage,
number of employees,
based on what timeframe?
A quarter a year,
five years,
10 years,
20 years,
50 years,
100 years.
I haven't agreed to those standards.
How can you declare yourself the winner?
How can you declare yourself?
Number one,
where no one else in the game has agreed
to the rules,
it's arbitrary.
There is no winning because there's no
end.
In other words,
companies are playing finite games.
Listen to their language.
They try to beat their competition.
What does that even mean?
It's the leaders and the companies that
understand the game that they're in and
organize their resources and their
decision making around the infinite
contest that outlast and frustrate their
competition.
All the companies that we've referred to
as the exceptions,
southwest airlines,
apple computers,
Harley Davidson,
they're the exception.
No,
they're playing the infinite contest.
They frustrate their competition is what
happens.
That's what happens because they're not
playing to win.
Say Jim Senegal,
the founder of Costco,
which is the company,
the only real company that gives walmart
or run for its money.
He says,
public companies are looking to succeed
for the quarter.
It says we're looking for the next 50
years.
You could hear him.
He's playing the infinite contest.
I spoke at a leadership summit for
Microsoft.
I also spoke at a leadership summit for
Apple.
Now at the Microsoft summit,
I would say 70 percent of the
executives,
and this was under the Steve Ballmer
days,
I would say about 70 percent of the
executives spent about 70 percent of
their presentations talking about how to
beat apple
at the apple summit,
a 100 percent of the executives spend a
100 percent of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach
and how to help students learn.
One was obsessed with their competition.
The other one was obsessed with where
they're going.
So at the end of my presentation at
Microsoft,
they gave me a gift.
They gave me the new zoom,
which was the competitor to the ipod
touch when it was a thing.
Right.
And I have to tell you,
this piece of technology was
spectacular.
It was beautiful.
The user interface was incredible.
The design was amazing.
It was intuitive.
I was one of those beautiful,
elegant pieces of technology I'd ever
seen right now.
They didn't work with Itunes,
which is an entirely different problem.
I couldn't use it.
Something else.
I'm sitting in the back of a taxi with a
senior apple executive,
sort of employee number 12 kinda guy,
and I decided to stir the pot and I
turned to him.
I say,
you know,
I spoke at a Microsoft summit and they
gave me their new Zune and I have to
tell you,
it is so much better than your ipod
touch,
and he turned to me and said,
I have no doubt conversation over
because
the infinite player isn't playing to be
number one every day with every product
they're playing to outlast the
competition.
If I had said to Microsoft,
Oh,
I've got the new ipod,
touch it so much better than your new
zoom.
There was,
can we see it?
What does it do?
How we have to see it,
because one is obsessed with their
competition.
The other is obsessed with why they do
what they do.
The other is obsessed with where they're
going and the reason apple frustrates
their competition is because secretly
they're not even competing against them.
They're competing against themselves and
they understand that sometimes you're a
little bit ahead and sometimes you're a
little bit behind and sometimes your
product is better and sometimes you're
not,
but if you wake up every single morning
and compete against yourself,
how do I make our products better than
they were yesterday?
How do I take care of our customers
better than we did yesterday?
How do we advance our cause more
efficiently,
more productively than we did yesterday?
How do we find new solutions to advance
our calling,
our cause,
our purpose,
our belief,
our why every single day.
What you'll find is over time you will
probably be ahead more often.
Those who play the infinite game
understand it's not about the battle,
it's about the war and they don't play
to win every day and they frustrate
their competition until their
competition drops out of the game.
Every single bankruptcy,
almost every merger and acquisition is
basically a company saying we no longer
have the will or the resources to
continue to play and we have no choice
to either drop out of the game or or
merge our resources with another player.
So that we can stay in the game.
That's what that is.
And you can think about the number of
bankruptcies and mergers and
acquisitions.
It's kind of proof that most companies
don't even know the game they're in.
You want to be a great leader,
start with empathy.
change your perspective and play the
game.
You're actually playing.